hey how she gonna brush my name is
gizelle atcha
we gonna play some good Zilla my
favorite game yeah yeah look at him go
[ __ ] laser okay that's better
alright my favorite game I can okay we
need to go oh it's awesome
Wow look at it down these holes how do I
[ __ ] wear this
there we go yeah this game reminds me of
a really shitty game I used to play on
Game Boy Color
I don't remember its name but if anyone
of you know you'll know how equally [ __ ]
it was use all good Zyliss moves to
bring down the TV tower watch all two of
them
how will I remember the attacks there go
get good silicone will destroy this TV
tower good still I hate being on
television
good sealer only watch YouTube 60 bugs
for this [ __ ] look at those shitty ass
graphics he's heading to the surface
looks like a [ __ ] PlayStation 2 game
oh there it is good versus Godzilla good
till I want but they'll have game is
important GJ good Xilai Yankee any DVD
DVD [ __ ] you both
the boats never liked me anyway all
right I'm gonna have to kill this boat
we can switch to the video but the data
collection point
like he can't even read Zilla do the
Hustle tipped it did it did it did
anything he shot me in the dick when
you're broke and you smokey the second a
demotion explosion the phone overdose in
Detroit raw you betray the law
I can only straight my gazelle Iraq
stupid machine
Godzilla hates machines and looking left
and right but still I can only stray off
claim on baby whoo I don't know how I
did that best game ever game in the
video game there you go one more baby
I'm up and out a rock yeah
that's why I killed the generator
because I really wanted food I thought
that would be like chicken nuggets in
there or some [ __ ] look how [ __ ] huge
I am don't you think I need some chicken
[ __ ] now gettin cold well my life is
pointless let's see now if they get
stage 2 is just walk straight for 2
minutes
click X for a couple times and then you
beat it because those those are my
favorite levels oh look it's another
chicken nugget dispenser well this one
better not be empty
what is this giant battleship doing here
shame on you battleship ammonia I like
how they're like he just wants food
don't worry he's an idiot yeah
what no chicken nuggets harina this is a
disgrace I still don't really know what
their [ __ ] to do I guess I'll go here
can't seem to move left or right this is
how Katella walk snap when you're broken
too smokey two seconds at the most
ah God's elegent wanna a tango tango and
check in now get what's going on a
cutscene it's me bro mr. Santee food
your I'm gonna [ __ ] that guy is my
chicken now I can't Jam it oh no check
it again [ __ ] you Sandeep oh can you
believe this then people don't scratch
my back right now veggie food is
attacking wha light chuckle no guys
oh boy cubes are fights wha no why
I'm Way more famous in you no one knows
even your name stupid [ __ ] almost
dead slap you I slap you hey oh oh you
forget about the generator ha [ __ ]
please I came in for chicken nugget and
I'm kind of late with some [ __ ]
general alright mister just chicken
nuggets to Spencer we have our
differences
Oh God well [ __ ] you now you're gonna
die
am i having fun oh sure yes yes eh I'm
happy
yeah has destroyed all generator
yeah [ __ ] no no God so furious I'm
shaking so angry all right Bryce I'm
gonna take this off because it really
hurts my face um if you enjoyed go ahead
and leave a like and I will not play
this game again
I'll see you bros in the next one stay
awesome bro brother ramiz again my
brother Harold over on the benefit
indeed side and now the widow will be
proud and they came in taking the
kingdom indeed